[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: So good
afternoon, everyone.
Thank you so much
for coming out.
We have an incredible author
and speaker this afternoon.
So without further ado, I'll
introduce Dydine Umunyana.
Dydine is the author of the
book "Embracing Survival."
She was appointed a youth
peace ambassador in 2013
for the Aegis Trust,
an organization
dedicated to the prevention of
genocide and mass atrocities
worldwide.
Subsequently, in 2015, she
became global mentor for peace
at Serve to Unite,
an organization that
cultivates peace through
creative service learning
and a global engagement.
Dydine is committed
to establishing
a dialogue between
people for understanding
their shared histories
and cultural differences.
Through her writing
and public lectures,
her goal is to pierce the
wall of silence that still
pervades much of our society.
Please join me in
welcoming Dydine Umunyana.
[APPLAUSE]
You can take that.
Good to see you.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: Thank you.
SPEAKER: So Dydine, welcome.
Thank you.
SPEAKER: Why don't we start
by taking us back to Rwanda
in 1994 and
providing the context
and setting for this
powerful and inspiring story?
DYDINE UMUNYANA: Well, back
in 1994, I was four years old.
So I was a baby.
And I lived with
my grandparents.
I remember the first day
of the genocide on April 7.
The genocide started April
6, the night of April 6.
So I lived in the Eastern
Province of Rwanda,
and the genocide had
already started in the city,
in the capital city
of Rwanda, and spread
throughout the country.
In the morning, in
Eastern province,
that's when the genocide
really began where I was,
in my grandparents' house.
And as a child, I remember 5:00
in the morning, my Aunt Agnes,
she woke us all up.
And as I walked in
the living room,
all my cousins were
sitting on the floor.
And my aunt was telling us
that we're going to church.
It was my favorite
activity in my childhood,
to get out of the
house and go to church.
So I was really excited.
And I screamed out loud to
her that I wanted to dress--
to wear my beautiful dress
that my grandpa gave me
the Christmas before that year.
And she shushed
me to not be loud.
If I need anything, I
should whisper from then on.
So I was a little scared,
but still wanting my dress.
And my little dress was
a white little dress
with the three butterflies.
And I loved it so much, so it
was my opportunity to wear it.
And she ran in the room, and
brought it back, and dressed me
up, and gave me a jar of milk.
We were more than almost
12 children in the house
because, before the
genocide, the Hutu government
used to kill or put in jail
the Tutsis who were young
and seemed to fight back.
So in the preparation of the
genocide, so they can succeed,
that was one of the
things they did.
Aside from buying
machetes and the uniforms
and all that was also--
yeah, that was part of it.
So my parents fled Rwanda
before the genocide.
That's why I was in my
grandparents' house.
But when we were about to leave,
she gave everyone, every child,
a little something
to eat or drink
because she didn't know
where that journey would end.
And so she gave me the milk.
But when we left the house,
the street was full of people.
People had been fleeing
all night from Kigali,
and they had been walking.
It's like a 30-minute
drive from Kigali
to Eastern Province,
where I was,
but people had been walking,
so they had a lot of things
with them.
They were carrying mattresses,
and food, children.
It was just a lot of people.
And we joined them.
I didn't write it in
the book, but I always
had this feeling
of a little shame
because I was somehow excited.
For me, it was really
exciting, that moment.
And I always felt it, and
I never even told anyone
because after the genocide--
when I was growing up, how
did I feel that excitement?
But as a child, I don't know.
So as we were walking
towards a cathedral
in the small city
of that village,
there was a lot of
whistles and songs.
The Hutus were singing songs
of hate in the name of god.
And the whistles started blowing
around ever in the hills.
And I don't know what
happened that moment
because I lost everyone.
SPEAKER: Yes.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: So you
probably remember in the book.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
DYDINE UMUNYANA:
And I found myself
in the home of perpetrators.
So they were my
grandparents' neighbors.
I played with their children.
And I didn't really quite
remember most of everything
because they just hated
me, but I didn't really
know because after
the genocide, when
I'm united with my
parents, my mom had
to bring me back there
so that I would not
end up like my father.
Because my father had
trauma and all of that.
And she feared that I
would have the same thing,
and she wanted to know what
happened to me because I
was in this home of perpetrators
and nobody that knew me.
My family wasn't there, so
I was the only one lined up
with so many other Tutsis.
You know, I was the
little one there.
And they started
killing everyone.
And as they got to
me, I asked for milk,
if I can drink my milk.
And I don't know where I got
the thirst to ask for milk,
but that milk saved me.
It did because when
they asked for milk,
it was almost a confirmation
to the perpetrators
that I am a Tutsi child, and
my parents are in the RPF.
They knew me.
They knew who I was.
So--
SPEAKER: The RPF
is the resistance.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: The
resistance in Uganda.
Both my parents were there.
And of course, those
perpetrators were my neighbors.
So they knew who I was.
They knew my parents.
They knew the whole background.
But asking for milk, I
would say this for maybe--
I don't know if I'm right, but
in Rwanda, before I came here,
they used to say "Bagels
are for Jewish people.
They love bagels."
So it was almost--
you were in the front of
Nazis, and you were a child,
and you're asking for a bagel.
So it's a confirmation
that you are a Jew.
So when I asked for milk,
culturally, Tutsis owned cows.
So in our culture,
children of Tutsis
drink milk in the
morning, and for dinner,
for lunch, everything.
So asking them for milk,
they paused and mimicked me
because they started
saying, "Oh, you
wouldn't be a child of Tutsi
if you did not ask for milk.
You wouldn't be a
cockroach or a snake."
Because they didn't
really see us as humans.
So we were a snake
or a cockroach.
But in that moment, when they
were mimicking me really loud,
someone heard them
inside the house.
And it was an elderly
man who walked out.
And he saw me in the line.
Almost everyone
was already killed
and were barely breathing.
And he asked them why
weren't they working.
So the way the propagandas
were on the radios,
they told the young Hutus, the
civil killers, that it's work.
Going out there and to
kill Tutsis, it's a job.
It's work.
You have to wake
up and got to work.
So when he walked
outside, really,
he was frustrated that
they're not working.
They're just talking.
SPEAKER: And he
was Hutu as well.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: He was Hutu.
He was the grandpa
of those kids.
And when he saw me in the line,
I don't know why he got pity.
But he told them
that they should
be ashamed of killing
an innocent child
when their wives are
carrying their children no
different from me.
So he rushed and saved me.
And he put me between
a pair of his legs,
and then they finished
everyone there.
And he threw me under the
bed, under a wooden bed
in the house.
So that was the first
day of the genocide.
And of course, there
were 99 more days to go.
And I was a child,
so I didn't really
remember most of those days.
But my mom, when my mom took
me back there, I had to--
I was almost seven or eight
because I had nightmares
when I was growing
up, and I would
dream of dead people, dying,
or people killing each other.
And I would think in
my dreams that they're
my family, the
people that I know.
So I couldn't really
my familiarize
my dreams and the reality.
Like, it would take me
time to go back to sleep,
when my mom would bring
me, everyone, my brothers,
and our babysitters,
everyone so she will confirm
to me that it was just a dream.
But when she helped
me, take me back there,
they started going
away because I
knew what really happened to
me because I could put then
pieces of that.
SPEAKER: Yes.
So I believe the stat is, yeah,
an estimated 1 million Rwandans
were killed during the
genocide, 20% of the population.
70% of the Tutsi
population was killed.
Give us your sense of
some of the drivers
of that level of hatred.
And what underpinned
that type of activity
that drove that level of hatred
and genocide in the country?
You mentioned colonialism,
the power of colonialism.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: That's
where I was going, you know?
SPEAKER: OK, I'll
let you go there.
Yeah, sure.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: That's OK.
I know because the
more I grow older
and learn more about how--
because I couldn't understand
how didn't my people kill
each other?
We spoke the same language.
We're all black.
We're in this tiny
little country.
And how in the world--
how did we end up
killing each other?
I did not really understand it.
Of course, I would just learn
how my father's entire family
was wiped out.
You won't learn anything
from my dad except the pain
that he's feeling because
he was already traumatized.
The Same with my mom.
So it was really a confusion
growing up in Rwanda,
having that history.
I couldn't quite really
understand the reason
behind it.
So when I was 18,
I got the chance
to go to the Rwandan
genocide museum
and learn the history and
background of the genocide
for the first time.
And that's the first time that
I was able to have compassion
even towards children
of perpetrators
because then I started
feeling them, how they feel,
if they know that their
family has done such a thing.
That's like a shame
that you carry on,
and you didn't even do anything.
So I learned so much about what
really caused the genocide.
But to really understand those
three months of the genocide,
you have to revisit
the colonial era
because before the colonial
era, the Rwandans did not
have tribes or ethnics.
SPEAKER: Or classes,
you implied as well.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: It
was classes, actually.
So the Tutsis were
the elite class,
and the Hutus were
the middle class.
And the Twa, they were poor
and the hunters, mainly.
So they lived together.
They shared everything.
And if you owned
more than 10 cows,
you would join the Tutsi class.
Because we did not have money
so we count the richness--
I don't know how to
say it in English.
SPEAKER: Yeah, that's fine.
Wealth.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: Wealth,
you count wealth.
It depends on how many
cows that you have.
So when the colonials
came, which I always
feel like were really--
it was in the early 1930s.
And for me, I feel like we can
never give what we don't have.
So when the Germans came
into Rwanda back then,
you know what was
happening in Europe.
It was the Holocaust
that was going on.
And that's the only thing
they brought into Rwanda.
So they started categorizing
Rwandans, studying them,
measuring their noses,
dividing them, and saying
that the Tutsis are tall.
They're lighter skinned.
They probably are from Ethiopia.
So they're not from
Central East Africa.
And the Hutus, they're the ones.
So they were really
measuring everyone,
putting them in the classes.
And they gave them ID cards.
And I don't know how my
people, they accepted that.
But I don't know because that
was way before I was born.
But they learned how
different they were.
It took a few decades
for them to really--
I guess it's easy to
teach hate because they
learned in only three decades.
And when the Germans
left and gave the country
to the Belgians--
because the Germans were
losing power in Africa,
the Belgians had Congo.
And the Congo is huge and
had diamonds and all that.
So they gave Rwanda to Belgium
so they can rule it together.
But really, Rwanda had nothing.
It did not have minerals.
It didn't have.
So it was just a little part
of Africa, small and beautiful.
They can just have
almost a headquarters.
So in 1959, they
killed the king.
I'm not 100% sure if
really the Belgians
poisoned the king in Burundi.
But when they did kill the
king, the Hutus took over.
So when the colonials
came into Rwanda,
they promised they'd
build schools, hospitals.
And all those privileges
were for the elite class.
So the Hutu children
wouldn't go to those schools.
So really, the conflict began
and from we are having more
than we are, and
this is our land.
How dare you have all of this?
So when the Hutus got in
power, they were already
angry at the Tutsis that
they are not from there,
and they are having
everything, so they
wanted to kill everyone.
So the civil war
really began in 1959.
And the child, the prince,
fled with a lot of Tutsis
in the neighboring countries.
And the Tutsis who stayed in
the country lived in fear.
So everywhere in
the country, they
started learning how the
Tutsis are not humans.
So those propagandas,
the name calling,
really began in the 1950s.
And there was a lot of
civil war in '68 to '72.
So really the 1994, it was it.
It was the time for--
SPEAKER: So the
culmination of all of that.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: --to erase
the Tutsi race from the planet.
And it was well
organized, well planned.
Because I remember
when I was growing up
hearing stories on how
the government will give--
because they used to train
young people who are 16, 15.
And they would train them how to
kill with traditional weapons.
And there's this one weapon.
They used to call it--
it's really interesting
because that's the one
they wanted to use on me.
And as a child, I never get it.
Like, even the weapon is
called "no pity for the enemy."
How can a child be an enemy,
because you really don't even
know who you are.
But when they were
training the civil killers,
they gave away
free small radios.
These radios, you could
charge them with the sun.
Now, this is a
very poor country.
But how hatred can
really work, you
will spend everything you have
to really succeed in hate.
So that's why the
genocide succeeded
in only three months
and a million people
were killed because neighbors
were killing neighbors.
And in one night, they
were ready for it.
In one night, those
radios, the only thing
that was on the radios
was go kill the enemy.
And it just happened like
that, but it was already
in the hearts of people.
People, they justified it
because they had already
learned for a long time that
the Tutsis are not human.
SPEAKER: Yes.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: Yeah.
So I think even in
the world today,
people justify calling
each other names.
And they forget that
when you're doing that,
you're actually losing
your humanity in you
because being a human
is having loving,
and being kind, and having
compassion towards each other.
But mostly, the
perpetrators actually
think of themselves as more
human as the other side.
SPEAKER: So let's
talk about your story
more directly because
the memoir really
focuses so much
on the family and
your familial relationships.
And they're a source of
both power and comfort.
But also there was a lot
of difficulty connected
with the relationship
with your mom,
especially with your dad,
the separation of them,
as you mentioned, when you were
a child, but also the valor
of the extended family,
people like Aunt Agnes, who
were rescuers in many ways.
So as a child, how did
you process family then?
How did it play a role in
your sense of survival?
And as you reflect
now as an adult woman,
those perspectives
on family, how
are they different or similar?
DYDINE UMUNYANA: I think
it cultivated something
in me that was, this
life is not just for me.
And I think it's
kind of like an idea.
It's a savior.
It can save your
soul because then you
become stronger than you
can think because you're
living for your siblings.
You're living for somebody else.
And I remember at 13 years old,
I couldn't understand life.
When genocide ended, I
had just met my parents
for the first time since birth.
So I was really, really
excited to experience love
from a parent for the first
time, but it was not there.
Their hearts were
already destroyed.
My parent had lost his siblings,
his nieces, his parents,
and he couldn't see life.
And that's the person I
was supposed to learn from,
how to love life and all that.
My mother was the same.
She was strong, very strong.
She never cried.
I never saw her crying
for her siblings.
But the other day,
for the first time,
23 years later, she
cried for her brothers
because she was in
a therapy session.
And then she called me, and she
said, I think I'm being weaker.
And I said, why?
She said, I promised
my family that I
stayed so that I can take
care of their family,
their children, but now I am--
so she never really
took the time to grieve.
And I think that's where, even
for me, it was more like--
even when I was
about to this is it.
I don't really want this life.
Why would god create life
if we're meant to suffer?
I remember I went into this
lake in the north of Rwanda.
And I had really,
really given up on life.
But when I got there-- we
lived with my father then,
and he was always traumatized.
And for some reason,
his trauma told him
that it would be easier if
he would be dead, but not
with machetes.
He didn't want us to
suffer as his family did.
So we really suffered from
that, and we fled all the time
from him.
And this time, I
said, this is it.
I'm done.
But when I got there,
for some reason,
I thought of my
brothers and sister.
And I thought, how are they
going to take the news?
How are they going to
live if I'm the oldest
and I'm doing this?
So I cried for them
and fell asleep.
Thank god.
And I woke up
around 6:00 PM, when
a guard was kicking me and
kicking me out of the beach
because children
were not allowed
to stay there later than 6:00.
So those kind of little
moments saved my life,
but I think it was more because
my family had this value
of loving the entire family.
Even when they found out
you were a long lost cousin,
you were-- they--
and there's that protection,
that when my aunt--
my aunt was my age, almost my
age during the genocide, Agnes.
And she took care of
all those children.
She was the only
adult in the family.
She never had children.
And she had my brother
through all those three months
on her back.
So even when she tried to
leave him, she did not.
Because you know,
fleeing, running.
And now I cannot imagine
myself doing what she did.
When I think of it, I
am like, would I really
be able to take care
of all these children
if anything happens?
But I think when you extend
yourself to be something bigger
than yourself, it
actually helps you.
It helps you more
than you can imagine.
SPEAKER: Yes.
So talk to us about
the escape to Uganda.
How did you get out ultimately?
DYDINE UMUNYANA:
During the genocide?
SPEAKER: During
the genocide, yeah.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: Well, so
in the Eastern Province,
it's the one main road that
goes all the way to Uganda.
And when we were
fleeing, we were
heading to Uganda, which we
did not really make it there.
But I remember a few
things because on the way
there, my dad, who was big
in the military in the RPF,
when he really came back,
he was looking for us.
And he looked for us first,
and he couldn't find us.
So we met in the street,
because he saw my aunt,
and he recognized her.
And then he came to us,
but I didn't know him.
My baby brother did not.
And he wanted to take us.
And my brother cried because he
didn't know who this guy was.
And my aunt looked at me.
She had her way of
looking, and you
know what she's talking about.
She was a really strong woman.
And she looked at me, and
she said Dydine, you go.
This is your dad,
and we will meet you.
Because she couldn't
really carry all of us.
So he put me on a motorcycle.
He was on a motorcycle then.
And we actually went back.
So my aunt was going to Uganda.
Because my dad was on a mission,
he brought me back in Rwanda.
Those are memories
that didn't leave me
because when we were going
back, there were dead bodies
everywhere in the streets.
And I remember, I
was vomiting on him
because I was holding
him from the back.
And then I tried
closing my eyes,
but it was smelling
because it had been days.
Yeah, so a few days
later, he left me
in a camp, a soldier's camp,
because he went on a mission
and left to me
with some soldiers.
And it didn't go well.
So he had to take me back to
my aunt because I couldn't eat
or drink or do
anything, and he decided
to find my aunt
because my aunt told--
Culturally, because of the
tension that was in Rwanda,
they already knew
that they did not
like each other, the tribes.
So even when you
were a child, they
would tell you, never
eat in a stranger's home,
or never take anything
from a stranger.
So I couldn't open
my mouth for anything
from anybody that I
don't know, except it
was my aunt or someone I know.
So when my dad took
me, I didn't know him,
and I didn't know anybody.
So I didn't have even water.
So he decided to take
me, find my aunt.
And we went to the
center, small center.
But things were really
getting bad because then it
was not just machetes.
The government, the military,
the Hutu government, the XFAR--
we used to call them the XFAR--
had started fighting
with the RPF.
So now it wasn't just not
running from somebody,
it was running from
bullets, from grenades,
and then it was war.
So this place
where my aunts were
hiding, where the
RPF will rescue
the rest of the few
Tutsis that are left
and put them in small
centers and guard them,
then the Hutu government would
throw grenades on those places.
So when I got there,
I guess I fell asleep
when my dad was taking me there,
and I woke up with my aunt.
And everything was flying.
So yeah, it was those
kinds of moments.
SPEAKER: So the title of your
book is "Embracing Survival."
And if you had to
try and locate what
where those things that allowed
you to survive and to emerge
to where you are today, sitting
on this stage, where do you
locate those critical things
that allowed you to hold on
and to survive during that time?
DYDINE UMUNYANA: Well, surviving
the genocide, it's one thing.
Then surviving after
surviving, it's another thing.
SPEAKER: Right.
DYDINE UMUNYANA:
Yeah, because it's
really hard because your
life just changes completely.
And of course, you don't
know any other life,
and that's the only
thing that is around you.
So it's really one way you'll
survive or then you die.
Most of the survivors did not--
most of them are like my dad,
or they already passed away
after the genocide, or they
became alcoholic, or drugs,
or prostitute,
just anything that
will just make them not think.
So it was really those
choices that we had.
And for me, I guess my
dad was more of, like,
learning from me because
even when I was having those
nightmares as a kid,
my mom would be like,
I cannot take it if you
end up like your dad.
And she was really strict.
I remember my biggest dream
was to go to boarding school,
to turn 12 and go to
a boarding school.
And I remember when I was
going to school, she told me--
you know, when you're sending
your kid to school, a girl,
you would tell her some
things like just take
care of yourself, whatever,
some sweet things.
No, she was like don't
dare get traumatized.
So I really did
carry that with me.
And I knew that if
I'm broken inside,
that's what I'm
going to be giving.
And I would try so hard
to do what I loved.
I loved singing.
I loved writing so I would
write my emotions down and sing.
I would become a church girl.
So I did all these
little things,
but I didn't know that
that was my survival
techniques until then I was
here, 3 and 1/2 years ago.
And I remember calling
my survivor friend.
And after weeks,
and I told her, you
know, I didn't know that
one can sleep all night,
all night long, without
anything, just sleeping.
So really, for me,
when I was growing up,
sleeping was luxury,
knowing that you're
going to sleep and
just sleep all night.
And I guess I ended
up learning how
to embrace that life,
and just the way
it was, and love
it the way it was,
and just knowing that there's
someone out there who's
living a worse life than I was.
That saved me.
And going to the museum,
seeing these children who
are my age who did not survive,
it made me, for the first time,
appreciate that person
who walked out and chose
to save me.
Well, I never met him.
I wish because
when we went back,
he had already passed away.
We met just his
wife, but I always
feel this gratitude
towards his soul, you know.
And those people are around.
We have a lot of good
people like that.
But he did save me.
And for some reason, I just
say like, why am I even alive?
So there is a reason,
and it's not just for me.
It's for the other
children out there
who are going through
the same thing
to know that there is hope.
Tomorrow is going to be OK.
SPEAKER: Which is what you're
devoting your life to now.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: Yeah.
SPEAKER: So we're going to open
it up for questions, if folks
want to queue up at the mics.
So bring us up to today.
What's the status
of Rwanda today?
How are you connected
to the country?
How have things changed?
What's your perspective there?
DYDINE UMUNYANA: I think
Rwanda today is OK.
I won't say that it's
perfect because it's only
been 23 years, and
it takes a long time
to teach peace
than teaching hate.
For some reason,
hate is really loud.
And when love is quiet and
people don't like to open.
It's vulnerable.
So we don't get to learn it as
much as when hate is out there.
But we are trying to have
reconciliation, forgiveness,
having survivors learn how
to forgive because it's
really more for
the survivor to be
able to live after the
genocide, the survival.
And I love that, after
genocide, they actually
learned that there was
no reason to have tribes.
So though it stirs some
people's hearts and minds,
but in our ID cards,
there's no tribes.
You're just a Rwandan,
which was a big step.
And I hope-- maybe it will take
generations and generations.
But I hope that one
day, younger children
will look at each other
and just see them,
see each other as humans,
not thinking twice about it.
Because that's how I grew up.
I grew up looking
at my classmate.
And the first thing
I'd want to know
is where they're coming
from, what's their tribe,
if they're my enemies.
And they're not.
They're just children like me.
So the country is trying
to move forward and heal,
but it will take a
very, very long time.
SPEAKER: Yes.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: Yeah.
SPEAKER: Any questions so far?
OK, so just saying on the topic
of the contemporary situation
in Africa, specifically,
I share with you
an article by Nicholas Kristof
of "The New York Times."
And the title of this
article was "Conflict
is More Profitable Than Peace."
And the article was about
the current situation
in the Central African
Republic and the genocide
that's been happening there
for about 14 years now.
And the premise
of the article was
that for us to
actually eradicate
poverty and all of the
difficulties in developing
countries, we have to
first deal with conflict.
And apparently 80% of
UN humanitarian budgets
these days goes to
dealing with conflict,
as opposed to getting people
food and those sorts of things.
So what do you think is behind
that kind of intractable issue
of conflict in places like the
Central African Republic, South
Sudan, Yemen?
What is the answer
there in terms
of dealing with that kind of
conflict that just continues
to perpetuate itself?
DYDINE UMUNYANA:
I think, for me,
the UN because they can look
over the whole entire world.
For me, I think it's really--
because when there's conflict,
it takes a lot of work
to fix it.
But there's ways that you can
see that conflict is coming
and prevent it
before it happens.
It's really less work.
Then you don't need the Cross.
How do you call it?
Red Cross.
There is a lot of work
when there's conflicts.
And it's not really profitable.
Well--
SPEAKER: Well, his
point was that it's
profitable for the perpetrators.
DYDINE UMUNYANA:
The perpetrator.
SPEAKER: Right, exactly.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: But for me,
I think the perpetrators,
they think they're
profiting, but they're not.
Because most of
the time, for me,
I think the perpetrators
doing the genocide,
where are they now?
They don't have a life.
They're in prison, or
they're fleeing all over.
But can you imagine if you've
taken millions of lives?
You're not really profiting.
Maybe in that moment.
But they just need
to be informed.
And most of the time, we
need to really educate
people on the importance
of profiting from peace
because it's more profitable.
We have more joy.
You are happy, and when you're
happy, everything makes sense.
SPEAKER: Yes.
DYDINE UMUNYANA:
Yeah, so I think
if they can be able to
prevent it before it happens,
share this world, because--
I guess I don't know
why, but when one person
said that we share the same
sky, we share the same sun
because we don't have
control over them,
so we can't really fight for it.
But we'd learned people should
think about it the same way.
Because really, what is home?
It's where your heart is because
you just find yourself there.
You never ask where to be born.
You never ask the color of
your skin or ask your family,
I really want to be born in
a very, very wealthy family.
No, that's never
going to happen.
You just find yourself there.
So why in the world
would you blame somebody
to be born the way they are?
It's just more of if you're
educating our children,
if we're educating--
in the curriculums, they should
really include peacebuilding.
They should teach children
to love each other
and just be as if you're
teaching history, but have
the importance of peace,
how it affects individuals,
and giving the children
that, just giving them that--
I think it's wealth.
Having peace is wealth.
It's life.
And if we don't have
peace, we don't have life.
So the UN, they should try
to create a system where,
if a child is born,
they don't even
think twice that oh, I'm
this color or I'm this
or that's that.
Just see ourselves
as humans, and we
won't have to deal
with people killing
each other or the entitlement.
This is my land.
This is mine.
Just knowing that.
I think the world
is not that poor.
We make it poor when we
have more than we should,
and then there are people
who don't have anything.
So if we can be able to
have compassion, and give
more, and prevent
this kind of killings.
Like in Rwanda, if we
had someone seeing it
before it happened, I guess
millions of people would have--
hundreds of people
would have been saved.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: Yeah.
SPEAKER: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for being here.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Your story
is amazing, and you
are truly inspirational.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Can you
tell us if you're
involved with any
organizations or efforts here?
As you said, you know,
hate somehow screams
and love is more vulnerable.
So I'm curious about efforts
that you're involved with
to help teach children or
just people in general about
compassion, and love, and
acceptance, and tolerance,
and all of that good stuff.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: Thank you.
I am.
I'm involved with
this one nonprofit.
It's called Serve to Unite.
And it was founded by a
former white supremacist.
He's my friend.
[LAUGHTER]
I met him the first time--
at my first talk
when I got here.
It was three months
after I got here.
My English was horrible.
But he had patience
to listen to me.
And I learned so
much about his work.
And I was curious because
before I came here,
I learned a lot about the
Civil Rights movements
and all these things,
the history of America.
And it was like, oh,
my god, this is a lot.
And I watched a lot of movies.
So when I met him with
all these tattoos,
and he has a really very
heavy voice, because he
was in rock and roll
when he was young,
so his voice is really strong
he told me about his work.
And I asked him,
how did you change?
And he said, you know, I changed
because I had a daughter.
And I was very young,
and I was a single dad.
And one day, we were at
the store in the car.
And my daughter saw
a white man walking.
And she said, oh, Dad, look at
that nigger, at four years old.
So for the first time, that's
when that word sounded wrong
in his ears.
And he told her to never say it.
And he tried, because he had
learned so much compassion.
When he was-- he was
at a thing in his 20s.
He had received a lot of
kindness from a Jewish person,
from a black person that helped
him because he always was drunk
or just in misery.
Because mostly when you
have the hate, really,
you're hurting yourself.
Yeah, you're not happy at all.
You just want to blame
the entire world because
of your misery.
But when he changed, he became--
he's a wonderful soul.
He's an amazing person.
Sometimes I tell him,
are you doing this
because you're paying back?
[LAUGHTER]
So he has this group.
He lives in Milwaukee.
And I speak to the children.
They actually designed--
the children are 14, 13.
They designed this cover.
SPEAKER: Oh, they did?
DYDINE UMUNYANA:
Yeah, out of denim.
So it's a huge
portrait they made
when I was finishing my book.
And they sent me a picture,
and I was like, oh,
my this is going to
be my book cover.
So these children, the Serve
to Unite, they learn peace.
And I share with them my story.
And they ask me questions.
Really beautiful children,
they're very, very authentic.
They tell you what they think.
So there's those programs.
And I work with OLASTEO.
My friend Aaron is
here and his wife.
They're the founder
of the nonprofit,
helping children to learn,
and to go to college,
to nicer schools, children
from underserved communities.
And with Aegis
Trust, that's when
I started my public
speaking, sharing my story,
and learning the history,
not just of Rwanda,
but what really is relevant
to the entire world.
Because I think we all are
looking for the same thing,
to be happy.
We just look for it
in different ways.
But if we can be informed on
how to find it in the right way,
I think we're able to change.
And I see with Arnold,
I see my friend who
used to be a white supremacist.
And I met this person
who's in the KKK.
Somehow, I find myself
in those situations.
But this guy, his name is Chris.
He was reforming.
So he was still in the
KKK, and I didn't even
know that the KKK still
exists, but it does.
So he was sitting across
from me and trying to reform.
But I saw how when we
were talking about love,
and he was really shy.
He didn't want to let it out.
And I asked him
so many questions.
Why do you do this?
And why did you do that?
But when he got to where I asked
him so are you OK with Muslims,
he was really aggressive,
really aggressive.
I got scared.
And then he could talk,
like, really talk.
And he was like, yes, I am.
And I was like, how about
children who are Muslim?
And he said, you never know.
You never know what
those kids have!
And I said, why?
In those dresses!
And I said, what do you mean?
He's like, maybe they have
something, a bomb or anything.
So then he became the
person that he is.
But when he was
learning how to reform,
when he was trying to be
a nice person in front
of a black girl, he was
really quiet and shy,
and he would even cry
because he told me
it was the first
time he's ever sat
across the table
with a black person.
And I think if we
can be able to switch
that, he can use that strength,
and that strength in him that
comes out when he thinks about
what he hates so much, to use
it when he's thinking
about why he loves so much.
And I think we all
have that capacity
because we grow what we feed.
We have those two
sides in ourselves,
and if we feed more light
in us, it really comes out.
Because I used to
not be this girl.
I used to be angry all the time
to everyone and everything.
Are you shocked?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's hard to
believe that, seeing you today.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: I used to.
Thank you.
And I used to.
Even my mom, I would spend
months not talking to my mom,
blaming her for not giving
me the life that I want.
And she doesn't really have any.
But I will still feel
like I want more from her.
And whatever that was
not going on in my life,
I would find somebody to blame.
The children of perpetrators,
I would blame them
that they have everything
and I don't, and it's
because of them.
So being in a
victimization mode,
it makes us, like,
giving ourselves
a justification of hating.
And really, when you
hate, for some reason--
I don't know.
Because even children, when
they don't want something,
they come out like
really strong.
It's like, I don't want that!
And then when they love
something, they may shy away.
But I think that's
what we learn.
So we can really be able
to teach how to be excited
when something
wonderful is happening,
or we've done
something wonderful,
then we can make him change
the way we see life and--
yeah.
SPEAKER: Yes, sir.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for being here.
You're incredible.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My question
is more about
the post-genocide recovery,
specifically the role
that the government
plays in that.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I think if you
look at the immediate years
following and the way the that
Paul Kagame has really embraced
international trade and
turned the economy around
really quickly is undeniable.
But then you fast forward to
today, almost 20 years later,
some people would say
he's an authoritarian.
I don't know if
that's true or not.
But I'm curious if you
think that you guys are
in a place where you can
now have more of somewhat
of a cleaner democracy,
or if you still
think that there needs to be a
lot tighter government control
to keep things on track.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: Thank you.
That's a really tough one.
SPEAKER: It's Google.
[LAUGHTER]
DYDINE UMUNYANA: I know!
I did not know what I
was getting myself into.
[LAUGHTER]
So Rwanda, it's a very
complicated country,
very complicated.
And as you can imagine,
after the genocide,
the country was a
mess, and we had
a lot of people, different--
let me see how I'm
going to describe this.
We had Tutsis who fled
Rwanda, the ones I explained,
in the 1950s.
So they grew up in
neighboring countries,
in Burundi, Congo,
Uganda, and Tanzania.
And after the genocide,
they say the cause
of the genocide or the conflict
was because the children who
were born and grew up in
the neighboring countries,
they were in exile,
and they were never
taken as Congolese or Burundian.
So they were always
refugees there.
So they always wanted
to come back home.
And for the Hutu government
that was in power then,
they told them
that the country--
Habyarimana, the
president, in his speech,
he used to-- sometimes
I say, how a president
can have the kind of speech?
But he would say that Rwanda
is like a glass full of water.
And if you try to drop a little
bit of one drop of water in it,
it spreads.
So he would say that
Rwanda is full already.
Nobody can come in.
If you try to come
in, it will spread.
And the spread was blood.
So when the Tutsis
tried to come in 1990,
they killed a lot of
Tutsis inside the country.
And even publicly, they
would say on the radios
that if you try
to come in, we're
going to kill your families
so that we have space for you.
So when genocide ended,
after the genocide ended,
the Tutsis who were living
in the neighboring countries
came back into Rwanda.
And the perpetrators fled,
were fleeing to Congo,
where they still have a rebel
group in Congo that is growing.
And there were other Hutus
who were going in jail.
And there were moderate Hutus.
And there were survivors,
which was 30% of the Tutsis
in Rwanda, a very small
number of survivors.
So there were all
these groups coming
in this little, tiny
country with a difference.
Some of them are excited.
Others have lost everything.
Others are coming back home,
or they have a victory,
or they are fleeing.
So it was a very, very
difficult country.
And just having all those
mixed feelings, it was hard.
There was not really
a quick solution
to fix what has just happened.
The first thing was to bury
the dead bodies and move on.
So for me as a survivor,
there was no time to grieve.
There was just no time because
you have to live again,
and on the same
speed as everyone
else who was coming home.
Then the economy
was not as horrible,
because they came back with
things, although the houses
were destroyed and all of that.
But that was for the survivors.
And we had to go in that
system, go back to school,
do this and this and this.
That's why my mom,
now, the trauma's
coming out now because
she never had that time.
And now with the
economy and everything--
before I came, I
worked in rural areas.
There are places where people
are really, really hungry.
Really hungry.
They have one meal a
day, a terrible one.
So of course, that is
happening because also
mostly the entire world stood
still during the genocide.
But after, there was
a lot of non-profits
that came into Rwanda.
So it's a very, very
vague situation.
I'm 27 years old, and I'm
not even into politics.
I don't know how I can make
really touch it or detangle it.
SPEAKER: Do you have confidence
in the current government
that's there?
DYDINE UMUNYANA: So I've never
known any other government.
I've never known any
other government.
That's the only--
SPEAKER: Sure.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: The Hutu
government, I was a child.
I really didn't
understand the system.
This is the only
government I've ever known.
And of course there's
a lot of change.
And leading a
country like Rwanda,
it takes a special
kind of individual
to be able to really
control those kinds of minds
that are completely--
yeah, I don't know how to--
SPEAKER: No, it's complicated.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: Yeah,
it's really complicated.
It's not perfect, but
at least it's not 1994.
Yes, at least we're not there.
And hopefully, we'll
never go back there.
Hopefully, we
learned our lesson,
and we will have peace
somewhere in the near future.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: Thank you.
I hope I responded well.
Thank you.
SPEAKER: So we're
basically out of time,
but one final question.
Oh, I'm sorry, sir.
I didn't even see
you over there.
How about you as
the last question?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: OK, I
think an easier one.
There's so much wisdom, and
you've had so many experiences,
and you're basically
an amazing person.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: What are your dreams
for your life going forward?
What do you want to do?
DYDINE UMUNYANA:
What do I want to do?
AUDIENCE: Maybe that's
a hard question.
[LAUGHTER]
DYDINE UMUNYANA:
I want to do this.
You know, I love
inspiring people.
I love, especially, children.
And I want to write more.
I want to touch as many
lives as I can before I die.
And it's hard.
I remember Aaron and I were in
Boise, I think, two weeks ago.
And it was at a human rights--
Wassmuth Center
for Human Rights.
And the director came to
pick me up from the airport,
and then he said--
Dan Prinzing is
really wonderful.
And he was talking to me, kind
of like what you did, kind
of preparing me for the talk.
And we were having a
conversation in a car ride.
And then he was asking me
how I feel when I do this.
And I said I'm fine.
But in Rwanda,
culturally, even if you
asked me, what did you have
for lunch, I wouldn't tell you.
[LAUGHTER]
So we always say,
where are you going?
I'm going down there.
Or how are you?
I'm fine, even if I'm dying.
So he asked me that,
and I said, I'm fine.
And then he said, you
know, a few years ago, I
had a friend who was
a Holocaust survivor.
Her name was Rose [INAUDIBLE].
And I asked her how she
felt after the talk.
And then she said, you
know, Dan, when I speak it,
you hear it.
And when I speak it, I see it.
And that really scared me.
Because I knew that this
is what I wanted to do.
And I know a lot of
survivors don't do it.
But then I knew that it takes me
a long time to get over a talk.
It takes me at least--
I have to be able to call my
friends right after the talk.
I have to distract myself.
It takes me at least a
few days or two weeks
to really get over the talk.
And I thought the more I
do it, I would get better.
So I asked him how old was she.
And he said she was 91.
[LAUGHS]
And I was like,
that's not promising.
How am I going to live my
70-something years doing that
to myself?
Maybe I should quit.
But when he was saying it
I said, oh, that's not fun.
I don't know if I'm
going to keep doing this.
And he said, but
Dydine, remember, she
started when she was 81.
So she really never talked
about it until she was 81,
and it was all inside her.
And I said, oh, maybe
because I started young,
maybe at 40 I'll be fine.
[LAUGHTER]
So I want to keep doing it.
I know sometimes it's hard.
When I met Aaron, when
I published the book,
I was quitting public speaking.
I said, I should just go work
somewhere in entertainment.
And I went to CBS and
"Entertainment Tonight."
And Aaron was like,
Dydine, when you're ready,
just let me know
because you have to be
out there inspiring people.
And by that time, I would
be sobbing on the stage.
Of course, I did cry
a little bit today,
but I used to really,
really cry, like sob.
And I was like,
this is not pretty.
I should just not do this.
So the more I do it, the
more I remember most of them.
Because the more I think
about it, it comes back.
But I think--
I take meditation classes now.
And my meditation
teacher told me, what
happens to you happens for you.
So it really maybe
happened for me
so that I can help someone else.
So I want to do this
for the rest of my life.
And hopefully, at
40 or 30-something,
I won't be still seeing it.
SPEAKER: Well, on behalf of
Google and the group here,
thank you so much for your time.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: Thank you.
Thank you so much for coming.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: There's
a new book signing
that will be happening in
the back, if any of you
would like to get
Dydine's new book.
Thank you.
DYDINE UMUNYANA: Thank you.